hello i love this light situation at the
back thank you i have worked so hard on
it so it means a lot to hear that
i know you have a blank background for a
reason so i think that works sorry
i'm sorry about it it's it's i don't
have much to work with right now but
don't get productions does a-plus work
and i'm gonna leave this in my interview
because the world should know it
i was reading in the production notes
that the role of lizzie wasn't as big on
the page initially as what we see in the
final film so what would you say is the
biggest difference between the lizzie
and the very first script you read and
what we see in the final product
oh the the secret the secret that she
carries was not originally in the in the
script
that's a big big change
yeah
with with that with that in mind it does
make me curious had you committed to the
project when you saw the role in that
form and if so
what was it about the character back
then that still had you eager to sink
your teeth into her
no i had not i i um i read the
description i was so
blown away by
um the themes explored within it
honestly i thought of the milgram
experiment initially when i read it
which was
you know i read about the milgram
experiment when i was like in high
school you know and it was always
something that stuck with me like this
disturbing element of society in which
one person can manipulate another person
to get them then flick hard on another
person right
um and then when i had i did a zoom with
with joseph kozinski our director and
this man's a visionary you know he he's
he's a real force and the zoom kind of
turned into like a brainstorming session
about ways in which he and i would kind
of want to
bring lizzie
to life um
and and we started talking about this
idea of well how
how do people weaponize shame you know
and essentially that's what abness is
doing
um
and
and then we started you know really kind
of digging deeper into what that would
look like for someone like lizzy and
and we talked about several different
things that could be her secret
um initially but
uh yeah yeah now i can't imagine anyone
else being in this role for that reason
as well i i can't imagine it not having
that added layer to it
so another thing that i was busy reading
in the production notes i think miles
said this was that you're the kind of
actor who likes to ask a lot of
questions on set as far as character
intentions go so is there an example of
a specific scene where you felt the need
to raise some questions and talk it
through and now the scene is better off
for it
oh i mean i don't i mean i think i'm i'm
just a collaborator i'm always you know
i i one of the things i love so much
about creating
a film or tv show or any sort of like
narrative is you you get to bounce
things off of each other and and
collaborate and go
but would she pick that up or would he
do that and like if i do this you know
what kind of reaction does that give you
it's a constant action reaction
right um beat by beat how are we
progressing this further and so
yeah i mean i think i think uh
one thing that was so beautiful is joe
as the director was so encouraging of
that with me
um
like
it's it's not
it's not something i take for granted
because it's not something you're always
afforded
is that level of collaborative spirit
serves this film quite well they're to
kick me out huge congratulations and
thank you for your time today thank you